what connects ancient african drum
circles to this coachella performance by
beyonce and what do historically black
colleges and universities have to do
with it if you've seen the 2002 film
drumline you know this electric feeling
all too well from hip hop inspired beats
to innovative dance routines black
colleges have been laying down classic
beats and grooves for years that set
them apart from the rest today we're
going to take a look at the roots of
hbcu drum lines and find out why this
percussive party is so entertaining
[Music]
when the movie drumline came out
i was in seventh grade right
and what the school had went on a field
trip but my class wasn't going i didn't
go i was like wait i'm the drummer
though in the school like i need to be
seeing this movie like i end up seeing a
movie about three times in the theater
that's that's one movie that
don't nobody want to watch with me
because i'ma say every single word i was
in eighth grade when the the movie drum
line came out
um i went to chapel hill middle school
choppered middle school is the feeder of
southwest dekalb high school which is
the actual band for the atlanta ant drum
line there were actually students
that got paid all the playing parts all
the cadences were parts of the south
dakar band program that was a high
school band i was a high school band to
understand how we got here we have to
take a look at the origin of black
marching bands as a whole throughout
america's military history many african
americans were drafted into the military
without property a career or a formal
education the union used these black
soldiers to drum up support for the war
and inspire people to enlist groups of
smaller military bands would travel to
community events to play patriotic music
they performed for militias to inspire
them for the perils of war francis
johnson was a leader amongst these men
and laid groundwork for black military
musicians he is the first african
american to have his composition
published as sheet music
in 1837 he was also the first
african-american musician to tour in
europe during the civil war there were
around 185 000 black men enlisted when
the war ended many uneducated black
musicians were left with nowhere to go
so they kept doing what they knew how to
do to get by menstrual brass bands
popped up to play music to move and
entertain a crowd minstrel c is a
controversial performance form where
stereotypically african attributes are
emphasized for entertainment this
blatantly racist form of performance was
often the only way black musicians could
earn any type of living by the time
world war one came around groups like
the harlem health fighters had emerged
officially known as the 369th infantry
regiment they mainly consisted of black
soldiers and recruits from puerto rico
the hell fighters were well known for
their military ban led by james reese
europe the ban not only performed in
battle but also toured europe playing
jazz and ragtime tunes during the war
the hell fighters helped introduce
europe to black american music despite
their cultural importance the harlem
health fighters spent the most time in
continuous combat than any other
american regiment they suffered the most
casualties too but where did school
marching bands come from for that we
have to go back to after the civil war
after emancipation schools for
african-americans were established in
the south today these institutions are
called hbcus
or historically black colleges and
universities
in the south the music culture is
so
prevalent it's so thick it's still
strong it's like
kids can grow up going to see a battle
of the bands and being influenced by
that um why do hbcus play such a big
role in marching band culture you know
the history of marching band is very
militant it's very straightforward it's
you know it's commands uh the military
bands were there to help the military we
got to give credit to dr william foster
at florida a m really who kind of kind
of changed the way hbcu bands appear and
how they perform and it gives us a sense
of belonging
[Music]
we we hear
we hear our music we produce our music
but to put it on a field with live
instruments gives us that that that
seasoning that a lot of other bands
cannot give
music directors like wc handy and dr
william p foster shaped the early band
sound by incorporating african music
traditions because of segregation these
bands developed independently and
created a unique sound centered in
african american culture there are three
primary styles of marching bands
military core and show style the style
we're talking about today and the one
most often used by hbcu bands is show
style also sometimes called traditional
show style banned tradition is rooted in
the foundations of african american
music like blues and jazz syncopation is
the concept of displacing the stress
notes in music
for example mary had a little lamb is
stressed in a classical european
approach with no syncopation whereas
something like this cadence has distress
on the offbeats
[Music]
call and response is the idea of musical
conversation you play something and i
play back in response to you this comes
from traditional african drumming
circles where the music was improvised
and felt as a push and pull between the
players african vocality is everything
you've heard in r b
rap jazz and blues all the runs the
rhythmic speech the vocal effects this
can even be felt on a drum line with no
singing through chants and call outs
[Music]
hbcu drum lines are also unique with
their style of composition
if we look at the core style percussion
battery only three instruments are
represented snare drum bass drum and
multi-toms also referred to as tenors
the additional tenor drum adds for a
driving rapid-fire middle voice and they
use marching symbols to add some top-end
flair both audibly and visually
you may have also noticed that the
equipment used is different core style
and modern military drum lines use rigid
harnesses that make carrying and playing
the drum much easier hbcu drum lines opt
to use straps and slings for an
increased range of motion letting them
incorporate dances and physical stunts
into their playing one staple of hbcu
bands is a dance routine called the
breakdown dr william foster of fan muse
marching 100 laid the groundwork for the
breakdown the breakdown is a special
part of the show where the band dances
and plays a mashup of current popular
music today hbcu drum lines are thriving
with dedicated events like the honda
battle of the bands the national battle
of the bands and other regional events
hbcu drum lines have even influenced pop
music so beyonce she pretty much raised
me like like the the first cd i ever
bought with my own money was writings on
the wall what was your reaction when
beyonce reached out to you
that's a whole i'm that's a whole story
i'm gonna try to condense it i quit my
corporate job in february 2018. i wasn't
really being fulfilled so a month later
i get a call from don roberts who is the
uh the owner and ceo of drummond live
and he says hey
i have an opportunity you have to leave
for two months
um but it's pay is for a very big artist
i cannot tell you who it is but i
promise you it will it will be worth it
i said to my homeboy i'm like hey man
you got that call from dave's like yeah
i got the call i was like i haven't
heard anything do you know anything
about it and he's like man all i know
is for beyonce i said who
he's like yes for beyonce i said
huh
i was okay i i have like rehearsal
footage in my mind to be honest
what was what was the energy like what
was the vibe like honestly speaking
speaking truly and honest
it felt like band practice every single
day
like beyonce's legendary coachella
performance
other pop stars like lil nas x have
incorporated hbcu bands in their art
right now there are 107 hbcus out of the
nation's approximately 5
300 universities the culture of the hbcu
drum line goes hand in hand with the
plights of african americans today
the constant fight to be relevant when
your slice of pie is the smallest has
pushed these groups to create something
unique and refined
much like jazz in its day
drumline is a cultural phenomenon
before you go i want to tell you about a
new documentary series on pbs voices
american veteran keep it close each
episode tells the story of a u.s
military veteran and a special object
they have from their time in service a
vial of lip gloss a small stone even a
microphone check it out at the link in
our description and let them know that
sound field sent you one more thing we
want to invite you to take the pbs
digital studio's annual audience survey
it helps us a lot if soundfield fans
participate you even get to vote on
potential new shows
there's a link in the description below
and if you have a few minutes we will
love your input
thanks